un pedido lucha por la vida cientos de
indígenas brasileños dejaron sus malocas
en la selva para sentarse durante una
semana en este improvisado campamento y
manifestar su rechazo a las políticas
del presidente ultraderechista y aix
bolsonaro
en este contexto actual del gobierno de
bolsonaro un gobierno que consideramos
anti indígena y que quiere a toda costa
exterminar y acabar con los pueblos
indígenas es aún más importante que
defendamos que unamos fuerzas para que
el argumento jurídico del marco temporal
sea derrotado en el supremo tribunal
federal no está da uso productivo no
federado kléber se refiere al proyecto
de ley marco temporal impulsado por el
ejecutivo y que ya avanza en el congreso
la norma implicaría una nueva
legislación para la demarcación de
tierras indígenas que reconoce como
tierras ancestrales sólo aquellas que
estaban ocupadas por las comunidades
nativas cuando se promulgó la
constitución de 1988 sin embargo muchos
grupos fueron desplazados de sus lugares
de origen durante la dictadura militar y
no lograron retomar hasta después de esa
fecha
bolsonaro un defensor de la
deforestación y la explotación de
recursos supone según los indígenas una
amenaza para el futuro de sus
comunidades y la selva amazónica
masiva las invasiones están aumentando
en el territorio así que tenemos
desafíos muy grandes contra la madera
contra la minería del oro contra las
empresas mineras contra los
ferrocarriles contra todos esos
proyectos gubernamentales mortales en la
corte suprema- retomará esta semana la
deliberación del proyecto que ya fue
suspendido en 2017 luego de masivas
protestas
la propuesta data de 2007 y fue iniciada
por el poderoso lobby agrícola del país